notre invité politique ce matin c'est
guillaume pelletier bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous un député de
leur est cher vice président délégué des
républicains on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représentée par stéphane
vernet bonjour stéphane bonjour rien
stéphane qui dirige le bureau parisien
du journal ouest france
et on commence par l'actualité autour
des policiers guillaume pelletier
hommage national qui sera rendu cet
après midi à éric masson ce policier tué
à avignon dans une opération anti drogue
et ce matin dans le parisien jean castex
le premier ministre déclare je suis
parfaitement conscient de l'existence de
cette violence forte elle est en partie
liée au fait que nous agissons nous
dérangeons qu'est ce que vous pensez de
cette analyse
qu'ils soient conscients c'est la
moindre des choses que ce que nous
vivons soit la conséquence des actions
du gouvernement
cet évident mais à l'inversé de ce qu'il
prétend je rappelle que qu emmanuel
macron a libéré avec son gouvernement
13500 détenus au début de la crise
sanitaire
il faut que chaque français l'entendez
le comprennent 13 mille prisonniers
condamnés dans les prisons françaises
ont été libérés au printemps dernier par
emmanuel macron et son gouvernement
quel symbole d'autorité et de fermeté
pour tous nos compatriotes qui ne
supporte plus ce désordre et quelle
insulte à l'endroit de nos forces de
sécurité policiers et gendarmes qui tous
les matins se lèvent pour protéger notre
liberté et notre vie voilà le bilan de
ce gouvernement
macron et les gesticulations très
bureaucratique et très marketing du
premier ministre ce matin ne changeront
rien au réel et au fait alors c'est
quand même pas le seul bilan il ya
effectivement une des opérations qui
sont lancées contre le trafic de
suppression il ya une augmentation de
budget de la sécurité une augmentation
du budget de la justice d augmentation
du nombre de policiers de gendarmes
oui mais le gouvernement n'a pas ri en
fait mais le domaine libération des
détenus
le record absolu sous la vème république
de la hausse des agressions
deux cent soixante mille 500 agressions
par an sous emmanuel macron 700 par jour
alors qu'il prenne conscience ce matin
après tous les drames que nous avons
vécu c'est je le répète bien mais c'est
la moindre des choses et nous ce que
nous demandons depuis très longtemps
avec les républicains avec christian
jacob avec eric ciotti puisque ce sont
des propositions de lois qui sont sur le
bureau de l'assemblée nationale
disponibles pour la pour la majorité
c'est une fermeté totale sur le plan
pénal en particulier avec par exemple
des peines plancher ou des peines
automatiques pour toutes celles et ceux
qui s'entraînent à nos policiers ou à
nos gendarmes et l'idée de porter la
peine de sûreté à 30 ans au lieu de 22
pour les personnes condamnées à
perpétuité pour un crime commis contre
un policier ou un gendarme
ça vous paraît insuffisant c'est une
c'est une bonne idée nous proposons ici
non pas suffisant cc vous savez c'est
l'idée d'un plafond maximum c'est la
moindre des choses mais ce que nous
demandons d'ailleurs avec les syndicats
de policiers
c'est un plancher minimum les deux les
deux un minimum et un maximum et surtout
un minimum pour qu'en france on arrête
vous avez vu les chiffres publiés par
vos confrères du figaro ce matin
92% des peines qui touchent celles et
ceux qui s'en prennent à nos policiers
et nos gendarmes ne sont pas effectués
puisqu'elle concerne moins d'un an de
prison
donc on voit bien que nous sommes dans
une société qui paye un lourd tribut à
ce que d'autres décennies de laxisme
ça c'est la peine plancher c'est à dire
qu'à partir du moment où là le lait de
la fraction commise ou le délit le crime
concerne une personne détentrice de
l'autorité publique
il est plus pop actuelle il ne devrait
pas être question d'aménager de pouvoir
ménager la peine exerce à le voir me dit
même minimales pour toutes celles et
ceux qui s'en prennent à nos policiers
et nos gendarmes et la suppression
immédiate mais pas que pour ces délits
et ses crimes de tous les aménagements
de peine en france est aujourd'hui le
grand problème tout le monde le sait nos
policiers et nos gendarmes sont
remarquables sont courageux font leur
travail mène des enquêtes interpelle
mais trop souvent nous sommes victimes
d'un laxisme pénale et bien c'est à
l'autorité publique c'est à dire aux
responsables politiques d'imposer ses
peines planchers pour qui les mesures
annoncées hier soir sur un durcissement
de la réponse pénale
elles vont dans le bon sens mais ne sont
pas suffisantes c'est ça mais elles sont
trop elles sont très tardive elle ne
rappelle pas que à la cause de tout cela
il y a une politique du gouvernement et
des mots rappelez-vous le président de
la république qui osaient évoqué le
terme de violences policières qui a jeté
l'opprobre sur toute une institution
donc moi je n'ai pas confiance en
monsieur macron je n'ai pas confiance en
monsieur castex mais puisque je suis
comme tous les français du côté des
policiers des gendarmes
je prends note des annonces de ce matin
qui vont dans le bon sens mais je
demande avec les syndicats de politique
nous allons y allions beaucoup plus loin
avec par exemple des peines planchers
pour toutes celles et ceux qui s'en
prennent à eux
là vous avez vous ai parlé de la réponse
pénale mais il ya aussi probablement des
moyens supplémentaires à apporter je
pense notamment au fait que vous n'êtes
plus en plus de policiers qui sont
agressés à domicile ou qui sont
identifiés dans les halls d'immeubles
il ya une espèce de ciblage qui augmente
ces derniers ces derniers mois avoir ces
dernières années qu'est-ce que qu'est ce
qu'on pourrait faire par rapport à ça
vous et notamment l'avocat thibault de
montbrial qui alertent là dessus en
disant attention il ya un phénomène qui
est en train de monter là on n'est plus
dans le pénal il ya des des mesures
particulières qui pourraient être prises
rapidement pour régler ce type de
problème
oui monsieur mme aubry elle a tout à
fait raison ce que nous pouvons craindre
avec l'addition de ces agressions c'est
un phénomène dit de convergence et de
ciblage et de ciblage et policiers et
gendarmes à leur domicile
donc il faut un jeu les 10 une ferme et
et pénales 2 que l'ensemble de la
société française
l'ensemble de la classe politique
l'ensemble du gouvernement soient
clairement avec les français du côté des
policiers et des gendarmes
et il nous faudra aller beaucoup plus
loin et c'est une réforme de longue
haleine sur tout un travail liées à
l'éducation
c'est à dire que cette éducation au
respect de nos institutions
cette éducation respect d'autrui elle
commence à l'école au sein de l'école de
la république où il nous faudrait être
intraitable et mettre hors d'état de
nuire celles et ceux qui très jeunes
s'en prennent déjà ou à nos professeurs
ou à nos politiques
dernier mot sur ce un pardon c'est pas
un dernier mot sur ce sujet parce qu on
a beaucoup de thèmes à aborder avec vous
selon une étude du cevipof ya au moins
60% des policiers qui choisiraient
marine le pen au second tour de la
présidentielle
44 pour son premier seulement 24 % pour
le candidat de la droite est ce que ça
veut dire qu'aujourd'hui vous
n'apparaissez plus comme une réponse sur
ces questions là non ça veut dire qu'il
ya une colère et une exaspération qu'il
faut entendre qu'il faut comprendre et
dire simplement il se trouve au policier
répond et nos gendarmes que la nouvelle
génération à droite à a pris la mesure
de ce qui est en train de se passer et
que nous avons l'avantagé par rapport à
monsieur macron madame le pen dans la
voir à la fois des idées très courageuse
très précises j'en ai présenté un
certain nombre et surtout la crédibilité
la compétence pour les mettre en oeuvre
quand je vois que dans nos rangs nous
comptons par exemple des personnalités
aussi compétente qu'eric ciotti et tant
d'autres eh bien nous sommes en mesure
une fois au pouvoir de rétablir l'ordre
dans notre pays on va parler de cette
tribune des militaires stéphanois oui
toujours dans le registre de l'ordre de
l'autorité les centaines de militaires
d'activé cette fois ci ont publié une
nouvelle tribune dans valeurs actuelles
ça ne vous a pas échappé
est-ce que quelques élèves quel regard
vous portez sur ce type de démarche est
ce qu'elle vous choque parce que je vous
la comprenez oui il a bien fait bien sûr
je la comprends d'abord vous ne me
trouverez jamais du côté de ceux qui
critiquent nos militaires premières et
les mots sont très fort cette fois ci
sur le lot autour de la thématique de
l'insurrection le chaos la guerre civile
franchement si je pense qu'il ya
peut-être que qu'à paris qu'on ne
comprend pas qu'il y ait une menace de
guerre civile dans notre pays il y a
près d'un millier de quartiers qui sont
identifiés par le ministère de
l'intérieur comme faisant
progressivement sécession avec les
valeurs de la république
tous les jours 700 agression à l'égard
de nous citoyens le terrorisme des
assassinats et des meurtres de policiers
et de gendarmes alors on peut faire
comme si de rien n'était on peut faire
semblant d'alimenter de fausses
polémiques en condamnant les messages et
plutôt que de s'attarder aux messages
qui est porté par ces militaires et aux
fonds à travers eux par toute la société
française
nous n'en pouvons
plus d'un pouvoir politique laxiste
incompétents qui fait croire que le
coupable
vos la victime comme le répétait encore
le garde des sceaux m dupond moretti qui
osaient se présenter comme le ministre
des détenus mais ça veut dire et à dire
le ministre des coupables alors que le
grand enjeu qui vient c'est d'avoir un
gouvernement qui se pose comme le
gouvernement des victimes dans notre
pays donc ça suffit
et ça n'est pas en alimentant ou en
allumant de fausses polémiques ou de
menaces liées à l'extrême droite qu'on
pourra rétablir l'ordre dans notre pays
il faut pas les sanctionner ces
militaires non ce qu'il faut sanctionner
ce sont les délinquants les terroristes
les criminels là et l'urgence pour la
société française certainement pas de
commenter du matin au soir et du soir au
matin des tribunes de quelques dizaines
ou centaines de militaires qui alerte
sur une situation que nous voyons tous
et à laquelle nous devons répondre non
pas par uniquement par des
commémorations est certainement plus par
vedette des bavardages mais par des
actes forts clair et crédible est ce qui
est curieux c'est ce que rappelait
lauriane tout à l'heure c'est quand même
on est on est dans un quinquennat où il
ya énormément de moyens qui ont été
redonnés à la police à la gendarmerie en
en des moyens humains les moyens
matériels il ya eu tout un un corpus
législatif avec un certain nombre de
lois sur la sécurité globale et j'en
passe qui ont quand même et prie pour
vous c'est le laxisme mais fait du
qu'ils font mais c'est dû mais parce
vous savez je vous donne un exemple ne
peut pas dire que ce gouvernement n'a
rien fait en la matière si je suis
député j'ai été maire et avant d'être
maire et chef d'entreprise j'avais été
professeur en collège et lycée
c'est comme quand on nous dit dans
l'enseignement on attend que des moyens
non quand on est professeur on attend du
respect on attend une ligne claire on
attend que nous refassions de l'école de
la république un véritable sanctuaire
pour l'émancipation team henry laurens
est la reconnaissance sur la police et
la gendarmerie arrêtons de penser qu'ils
ne nous demandent que des moyens
matériels
ils demandent avant tout un une
reconnaissance totale de la nation deux
une prise de conscience de la classe
politique que grâce à eux
policiers et gendarmes nous vivons en
sécurité 3 une réponse pénale déterminée
et adapté qui dit une chose simple
à tout délit une sanction
c'est un principe d'éducation c'est un
principe universel qui est aujourd'hui
balayé par une classe politique qui
entre saint germain des prés et les
dîners en ville est incapable de prendre
la mesure de ce que ressent la société
française eh bien nous avec les
républicains notre priorité absolue sera
en 2022 de rétablir l'ordre
l'autorité et la loi partout et pour
tous on va parler de la crise sanitaire
les députés ont donné cette nuit leur
feu vert au passage iter pas sanitaire
qui ne sera pas nécessaire pour les
actes de la vie courante mais qui sera
nécessaire pour les grands
rassemblements
une jauge de 1000 personnes étaient un
temps évoquée n'a finalement pas été
inscrite dans la loi est ce que pour
vous c'est un bon compromis ce qui a été
voté hier
d'abord je vous admire d'avoir très bien
résumé autres en tout cas tenté de
résumer à la fois l'interview très
bureaucratique et opaque du premier
ministre et les débats qui commencent à
l'assemblée nationale nous ce que nous
demandons et je le dis au nom des
artisans des commerçants des
restaurateurs des travailleurs des
entrepreneurs des acteurs touristiques
chez moi en sologne en vallée de la
loire en vallée du cher mais dans toute
la france sortons de la règle
bureaucratique faisons du sur mesure
remettons de la souplesse ouvrons les
portes et les fenêtres pour revenir à la
vie et pour revenir à la croissance
et arrêtons avec les trucs les machins
incroyablement complexe en tout cas moi
je n'y comprends rien alors on a trois
dates le 17 mai le 9 juin le 30 juin
on a des jauges modulable alors il a
c'est une personne tous les mets 4
mètres carrés là tous les 8 mètres
carrés 500 personnes 1000 personnes 5000
personnes c'est possible pour un
restaurant c'est pas possible à
l'extérieur où l' inverse fin bref oui
je pense qu'ils ont dû est une dix ou
quinze énarques ou bureaucrates à
à se mettre dans une pièce pour rédiger
un truc aussi compliqué ce que nous
attendons nous est ce que je nous
défendre en tant que parlementaires
c'est de la simplicité de la souplesse
du sur mesure pour garantir bien sur la
santé des français
mais pour pouvoir enfin relancer
l'économie française sont bien à quelle
échelle juste par département car oui je
crois vraiment et là j'en veux beaucoup
au précédent la république là encore je
crois beaucoup que l'alliance que je
mesure moi tous les jours entre les
parlementaires d'un département les
maires d'art département et le préfet du
département
c'est c'est la bonne celle là le fait le
bon niveau pour à la fois appliquer des
règles nationales il n'est pas question
de faire tout et n'importe quoi bien
entendu parce que la santé 50 mais de
redonner de la liberté de la souplesse
et de l'oxygène à nos travailleurs et à
nos entrepreneurs je crois que ce trio
préfets maires parlementaires et le très
bon niveau alors dans l'interview que
jean castex a donné au parisien donc
cette interview trouver bureaucratique
et opaque
le premier ministre dit nous sommes
enfin en train de sortir durablement de
cette crise sanitaire est ce que cette
fois ci c'est la bonne où il est trop
optimiste pour vous vous avez vous avez
envie d'y croire avec lui ou wii avec
tous les français bien entendu là encore
oui j'ai l'air tout d'abord je ne suis
que député d'opposition donc je ne comme
vous je ne détiens pas toutes les
informations que l'exécutif et recevez
le sentiment que la stratégie vaccinale
et axione et c'est qu'en fait on va
pouvoir réduire durablement la pression
sur l'hôpital parce que c'est ça l'enjeu
bien sûr l'enjeu est là ça a l'air de
marcher quand même non et l'enjeu avec
beaucoup de retard par rapport à garder
ce qui se passe ailleurs en europe et
dans le monde
je pense faut penser aux prises à des
jeux non je pense que nous devons il ne
dit pas suffisamment d'ailleurs vacciner
matin midi et soir sept jours sur sept
jour et nuit y compris les dimanches et
les jours fériés
quand on voit là encore tu fouilles
manuelles mâcon oui enfin je suis
d'accord avec manuel da cruz sauf que
lui les présidents de la république et
moi je suis député d'opposition donc
c'est lui qui a les manettes pour agir
donc c'est bien vous êtes en train de
vous avez peur que la vaccination marque
le pas par exemple mais elle marque le
pas remis c'est le cas on va à peine le
premier se le reconnaît lui même
atteindre les chiffres promis par
emmanuel macron et on verrait un million
de vaccinés au 10e
la green et c'est quand même moi nous
seront vaccinés plus tard nous serons un
pays pour retrouver une vie normale et
une dynamique économique attendue est
donc je demande au gouvernement mais
comme tous les français de tout faire en
lien avec les pharmaciens qui ne sont
pas suffisamment utilisé en lien était
médecin généraliste qui ne sont pas
suffisamment utilisé de tout faire pour
permettre à chaque français qui le
souhaitent de se faire vacciner
jean castex et où se montre aussi très
optimiste sur la sortie de crise en fait
sur la relance économique on a
l'impression que l'exécutif table sur
une espèce d'euphorie post co vide
est-ce que là ils sont trop optimistes
aussi ou est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est possible qu'on ait qu'on assiste à
une bonne surprise
un vrai rebond que les français
débloquent leurs épargnes et se
remettent à sortir et à vivre avec
beaucoup plus d'appétit que prévu avant
qu'on peut que l'espérer
évidemment mais là encore il faudra
tirer les leçons de cette crise
sanitaire prendre la mesure de la crise
économique et sociale qui vient avec
pour moi un défunt deux sujets d'abord
le sujet très lourd des dépenses
publiques et de la dette
mais plus largement la question centrale
de la valeur travail
le grand problème en france c'est que
aujourd'hui tout est fait par la
puissance publique pour encourager le
non travail pour encourager l'assistanat
et qu'il faut donc créer un électrochoc
alors c'était très bien le chômage
partiel en période de crise mais à une
condition c'est qu'on explique désormais
à tous nos compatriotes au nom de celles
et ceux qui font des efforts au nom de
cette v ceux qui n'ont jamais failli ni
faibli pour se lever le matin travaillé
et porter la france que celles et ceux
qui travaillent vente enfin
on pensait à la hauteur de leurs efforts
et qu'aujourd'hui l'écart entre les
revenus du travail et le revenu
l'assistance est si faible et si ténu
que rien n'est fait pour encourager le
travail et que tout hélas est fait pour
encourager de non travail
c'est l'un des grands enjeux des mois et
des années qui viennent et certainement
du prochain quinquennat
un mot sur le climat puisque les
sénateurs ont voté cette nuit le texte
qui inscrit le climat dans la
constitution ils ont voté mais ils ont
modifié du coup le référendum promis par
emmanuel macron est pour l'heure
impossible
est ce que finalement la droite n'est
pas tombé dans le piège tendu par
l'exécutif qui va vous faire passer
auprès de l'opinion publique pour des
conservateurs sur les questions
économiques et non mais médias que
monsieur macron qui croise à d'abord qui
croient qu'ils croient quel homme quelle
femme de bon sens et de bonne volonté
peut croire une seule seconde que la
petite formule de monsieur macron
inscrit dans l'article 20 de la
constitution changerait la donne en
matière d'environnement
qu'ils arrêtent de nous prendre pour des
imbéciles voilà la question de
l'écologie elle est trop sérieuse pour
être confiée aux écologistes est
manifestement pour être confiée à
monsieur macron la vérité sur l'écologie
c'est un que la france est globalement
exemplaires et deuxièmement que les
français émond avec eux nous ne voulons
plus d'une écologie punitive de la
morale de la taxe et de l'impôt il nous
faut deux choses 1 être beaucoup plus
intraitable à l'égard des états et des
multinationales qui ne respectent rien
des engagements internationaux
ça c'est vrai 2 basculer d'une écologie
punitive à une écologie positive pour
tous les citoyens
c'est à dire que nous nous mettons sur
la table des propositions et damien abad
par exemple à quand une baisse de
l'impôt sur les sociétés pour toutes les
entreprises vertueuses en environnement
à quand une tva à 0% pour la vente
directe pour nos agriculteurs pour la
rénovation énergétique de nos logements
privés pour les transports collectifs
accord la gratuité de la carte grise
pour les véhicules propres
plein de propositions très concrètes
pour une écologie rural et positive qui
va réconcilier très concrètement est
beaucoup plus concrètement que ce que
dit le président la république les
français avec la notion évidemment
vertueuse d'environnement et d'écologie
on va parler politique pour terminer
dernière question avec stéphane jean
castex y revient dans cette interview
dans le parisien aujourd'hui en france
il revient sur ce qu'on peut appeler la
ferme muselier un peu schématiquement il
parle d'une exceptionnelle violence chez
les républicains il dit j'ai vu un parti
politique tirer à boulet rouges allant
jusqu'à dire que s'allie avec le
rassemblement national de la majorité
présidentielle ce serait la même chose
qu'est ce que vous répondez au premier
ministre ce qui est sidérant c'est qu'il
soit sidéré parce que en france est en
démocratie on a le droit et nous le
revendiquons les christian jacob donc
j'ai admiré le courage de refuser de se
soumettre au président de la république
et à ce duel mortifère entre monsieur
matheron et madame le pen
80% des français il pourra leur
expliquer ne veulent pas du duel macron
le pen et donc sont fiers aujourd'hui
d'abord un grand parti de la droite
républicaine qui a dressé une frontière
étanche avec le maquereau nice mme
pascale et christian jacob et l'ensemble
de nos amis nous avons très clairement
dit les choses tous ceux qui veulent
aller vers macron ont le droit de le
faire mais ils ne font plus partie des
républicains aux non plus le soutien des
républicains les républicains c'est une
grande formation populaire indépendante
qui n'a rien à voir avec le maquereau
nisme et qui va proposer dans les
semaines qui viennent une alternative
populaire à celui qui apparaît
aujourd'hui comme le pire président de
la vème république s'est pas trop tard
est-ce que le mal n'est pas déjà fait
notamment est-ce que pas là la région
provence alpes côte d'azur et déjà n'est
pas déjà perdu
non je veux voir à thierry mariani qui
va gagner la région savez on ne perd
jamais en politique à être fidèle à ses
convictions et être la conscience quand
même qu'en termes d'image sas mais
écoute dégâts l'image n'a aucun intérêt
aucune importance en politique je
termine un peu aussi votre élégance sont
les convictions et je suis persuadé
qu'avec
la clarté qui est la nôtre aujourd'hui
enfin à l'égard d' en marche et
d'emmanuel macron beaucoup de français
beaucoup d'électeurs de droite et
beaucoup d'abstentions et donc ils
viendront qualification oui c'est une
clarification salutaire c'est un mal
parce que se tut une fut une semaine
compliquée vous avez raison qui va
accoucher d'un bien la clarté les
républicains n'ont rien à voir avec enel
macron et la république en marche les
républicains c'est une grande formation
populaire avec des parlementaires au
sénat et à l'assemblée nationale des
milliers d'élus locaux et des millions
de français qui ne veulent pas du duel
macron le pen et qui veulent préparer en
une grande alternative à cette politesse
sur l'alliance entre gilles platret donc
républicain avec debout la france en
bourgogne franche comté on l'a on est on
est il ya la clarté aussi où est sa
marque
oui ça n'a rien à voir mais ça n'a rien
à voir debout la france c'est un parti
qui vient du gaullisme son leader a
reconnu avoir fait une erreur en 2017 et
je ne m'en sers les problèmes avec
marine le pen et la demande nationale
voilà je ne vois aucun problème n'a pas
hésité et je soutiens totalement gilles
platret dans sa volonté de rassembler
tous les républicains tous nos alliés
centristes comme il a choisi debout la
france pour proposer une alternative au
maquereau nisme le grand enjeu pour la
droite c'est de proposer une alternative
au maquereau nisme plus que plus qu'un
marine le pen est au rassemblement
national basse et liés puisque emmanuel
macron mène à marine le pen avec marine
le pen mène à emmanuel macron si on ne
veut ni l'un ni l'autre
il n'y a qu'une alternative possible ce
sont les républicains un mot juste sur
ce qui se passe dans votre région centre
val de loire c'est nicolas forissier en
votre candidat vous avez choisi de ne
pas concourir à cette élection est ce
que selon les résultats du premier tour
une alliance avec marc fesneau le
candidat du modem et donc de la majorité
présidentielle ou semble envisageable ou
dentelle quand on 2015 était sur la même
liste armure créneau nicolas forissier
non alors moi j'ai fait le choix vous
avez raison de mon département de loir
et cher de leur assise demande locale et
dont j'en suis je suis très fier pour
les élections régionales en tant que
député de loir-et-cher numéro deux des
républicains ma position d'une clarté
absolue comme en région sud est comme
ailleurs aucune alliance au premier
comme au second tour avec les partis la
majorité présidentielle nous les
combattons et illimité avec marché ne
riez pas été sur la même liste il y
avait en 2015 c'est lui qui a voulu
venir avec nous à une époque où il
prétendait combattre françois hollande
ces gens là ont décidé de trahir et de
rejoindre emmanuel macron c'est leur
droit
granby au grand malheur face nous nous
sommes clairs car et cohérent pas
d'alliance avec emmanuel macron pas
d'alliance 1er 2e tour est-ce que ça
c'est pas une politique qui peut
conduire dans le cadre de triangulaire
de conan guilers à une bascule certaines
régions au rassemblement national au
second tour
mais tout bascule vers ce parti serait
l'immédiat de conséquence de la
politique d' emmanuel macron notre rôle
n'est pas de thé attendre emmanuel
macron de défendre madame le pen je vois
bien je ne vous en veux pas je vous
poserai que j'aimais beaucoup d estime
pour chacun de vous deux mais la france
ne se résume pas monsieur macro madame
le pen il y à des millions de français
qui ne veulent ni de l'un ni de l'autre
et qu'ils ont avec les républicains
enfin la possibilité d'avoir un choix et
un vote libre souverain et cohérent pour
tourner la page du maquereau nice mais
rétablir la valeur du travail
la valeur de l'autorité la valeur de la
liberté dans notre pays sané paris en
démocratie et merci beaucoup merci merci
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin
stéphane en garde la une de ouest france
vignerons et arboriculteurs pensent
leurs blessures du gel c'est à la une de
votre journal
merci messieurs
[Musique]